yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing pirate one two three four okay
color rosolie mo hmm by g7 is kind of
normal okay this one hmm there's
probably more than one good way to do it
but rocky one cannot be a bad move not
sure what I recommended him repertoire
okay this is an argument maybe for not
playing rocky one even though well
let's see what happens here that doesn't
look all that simple for black he loses
quite a bit of time I mean he cannot
allow me now to check on d5 I think that
would be structurally too bad so I'm not
sure what he's playing Knight c7 is
extremely slow yeah there isn't that
isn't particularly like fast either but
you can see the point
so just to be 3 or what are we doing
here hmm
yeah probably just to b3 c3 might be
answered with 93 this is something that
I have to definitely be aware of he's
got some issues there with them the
bishop iam on f8 not easy to develop
yeah this H pawn idea is not that is
quite quite frequently seen and nothing
that is surprising or anything I just
wonder how would you do this correctly
if I go d3 here now there might be Queen
j5 attacking the rook and the pawn I
have to watch out that my pawn isn't
getting so weak it's however this is a
very slow way of playing I mean I got 92
c4 next if he goes too near 5 Queen e2
okay this is a different way of
attacking the pawn
so Queenie - oh yeah I can actually play
Bishop f4 and that is to be preferred I
guess b5
okay yeah maybe this is hmm the only way
to really develop the bishop on c8
that's possible not sure if I need to do
that really not but it looks useful
[Music]
okay night see for now one night a thigh
probably but okay let's see that I don't
spend sorry more time maybe h3 was an
idea to be honest actually oh is
canceling alone that okay the main idea
of this is to prevent 95
maybe him he should go h3 yeah
okay now a 601 not now pushing this back
should be quite okay Queen f3 is a funny
move they're threatening threatening
okay five but Jackie it makes no sense
if him yeah anyhow okay g3 but no 25 he
cannot play g3 is kind of debatable of
course
so I take it he takes it rookie six I
mean that is it looks extremely
dangerous
[Music]
but it's not winning it's not winning
for me at least I don't don't see it
[Music]
hmmm I don't see it I don't see anything
great this is not really great
this is my farm that's by far not ideal
yes no Queen move the bishop is hanging
when aid so we're going to trade Queens
now which I did not originally wanted to
do for sure this threatening okay five
it's maybe a rook c5 is probably a bit
silly it's a super obvious threat
maybe just Bishop c5 okay Queens still
cannot move maybe I had something to eat
six there should be six or something
like that
nine seconds nine seconds is not a lot I
don't think he will actually take but
you never know
hmm I was stepping right into this this
discovery nope not good yeah the the
having no time situation irritated me
quite heavily I don't know if I can
actually take it from me not
yeah it's not not very nice still not
really too much
yeah it's a very annoying oops
what's that that was a Muslim very lucky
yeah right okay I mean I was certainly
completely winning at many points oh
that's my kitchen timer
you cannot pause this actually I don't
think I can
I'm sorry about it it's not Sarge and I
have a minute or so to check this so
yeah I mean here it was okay for like
yeah with age three yeah I think he
should have done that earlier but the
way it the way it I'm really mostly
curious on how I could have won the game
clean because that was certainly
possible I came around here but that
must be winning more or less age three
age three years it could move simply
preventing the counter play okay the
engine gives plus one which is not
completely winning but it looks strong
and he thinks things things get murky
and like I already GERD f6 and he I
couldn't find something the engine
actually this is the most obvious thing
to do but I couldn't really make it work
like here Knight b6 maybe okay I didn't
see that one I was only seeing Queenie
657 and as so no way forward
that is a pretty cool way to do it wow
that looks extremely dangerous
yeah probably this is what I have to do
I really couldn't find a move and played
the screen g6 business and him yeah here
must be better no doubt the points are
all weekend but I couldn't really
couldn't really make it yeah I couldn't
do that convincingly
yeah I'm sorry I have to have to
absolutely go and check in the kitchen I
didn't expect some of the game to be so
long yeah thanks for watching